segundo bloque de economía en directo
américa de francés 24 me encanta porque
aquí me van a pagar lo que me deben pero
más adelante ya ni así vamos a hablar de
argentino porque hay una ministra de
economía en ese país y raúl se llama
silvina batakis ella llega en reemplazo
del economista moderado martín guzmán
quien el pasado sábado renunció
abruptamente en medio de una lucha
interna de poder en la coalición
gobernante de alberto fernández y a
quien se le unieron también varios del
equipo económico en solidaridad con
martín guzmán renunciaron el anuncio lo
hizo bien entrada la noche del domingo
la portavoz presidencial
gabriela cerrutti en un tuit en el que
recordó que batakis fue titular de
economía de la provincia de buenos aires
entre 2011 y 2015 ahora silvio ataques
de 53 años es considerada una economista
heterodoxa es decir poco ortodoxa poco
apegada a las reglas y ahora tendrá que
lidiar con el que es probablemente raúl
el ministerio más importante de
argentina porque porque va a tener sobre
sus hombros luchar contra una inflación
superior al 60 anual también contra una
pobreza de más del 40% un alto déficit
fiscal crecientes temores sobre posibles
impagos de deuda y un peso profundamente
devaluado entre muchos otros problemas y
en españa' la imagen de empleada pero
también hay crisis de personal
bueno el número de personas registradas
como desempleadas como desempleadas en
españa cayó al nivel más bajo desde que
la crisis financiera mundial golpeó al
país en octubre de 2008 según datos del
ministerio de trabajo publicados
precisamente este lunes cuando se da
comienzo a la temporada de vacaciones de
verano ahora hay 20 tres millones de
personas empleadas formalmente y 2,9
millones de desempleados y es que esta
es una buena época laboral en españa ya
que los hoteles restaurantes y otros
negocios turísticos contratan a más
personas sobre todo ahora después de
pandemia cuando ha subido el turismo sin
embargo los empleadores enfrentan un
nuevo dolor de cabeza que es contratar
gente raúl a la escasez de mano de obra
es algo que los sindicatos atribuyen a
los bajos salarios y a las jornadas de
trabajo extremas escuchemos qué piensan
de lado y lado
que es difícil pues yo creo que
básicamente es lo que se paga el sueldo
la reforma que hemos tenido desde hace
muchos años en la cual se han perdido
derechos y claro
se trabaja mucho y se cobra poco hay una
crisis del camarero por todo lo que
hemos hablado de los salarios o de las
horas tienen que echar de más pero es
que yo creo que la crisis es una crisis
estructural
economía y del trabajo no solamente de
la hostelería y si es verdad que no hay
camareros lo que va a pasar a futuro es
que lo mejor no va a haber tantos bares
como se dice que hay y aquí no hay
incumplimiento de pago de la deuda como
algunos países angela indicadores
indicadores 'wall street' descansa hoy
por ser día festivo y en europa
amanecieron al alza los principales
mercados a pesar de la publicación del
pasado viernes de nuevos datos
desalentadores sobre la inflación que
dice que alcanzó el 86 por ciento
interanual en junio este es su nivel
histórico más alto desde que iniciaron
registros en
1997 y no impacta tanto las cosas porque
ya el mercado lo da por descontado ahora
las bolsas asiáticas sí cerraron mixtas
en japón le voy a destacar una noticia
raúl y es que acá de y que es el segundo
operador de telefonía más grande del
país perdió el lunes 1 67 por ciento
aunque llegó a bajar casi un 4 por
ciento sus acciones después de
experimentar problemas de red durante el
fin de semana que dejaron a más de 40
millones prácticamente incomunicadas la
empresa dijo que ya se restablecieron
las comunicaciones pero todavía muchos
usuarios están teniendo problemas para
realizar llamadas entre otros la
interrupción comenzó en las primeras
horas del sábado y fue causada por un
mal funcionamiento de la red y afectó
servicios que van raúl desde datos
meteorológicos hasta entrega de paquetes
y servicios bancarios o se quedaría un
fin de semana sin internet nada menos no
lo sé la verdad creo que entre 16 y
porque además no tiene que estar pues
comunicado y actualizado con todas las
noticias
sí señor 6 no sobreviviría yo sólo diría
yo creo que yo no siempre al día danny
78 62 por ciento fue la inflación anual
de turquía en junio es la más alta en 24
años si bien muchos países están
experimentando aumento de precios los
críticos como ya lo hemos dicho acá
varias veces culpan a las políticas
económicas del presidente recep tayyip
erdogán que insiste en bajar las tasas
de interés para impulsar el crecimiento
el resto de bancos del mundo las están
'sub les está subiendo pues algo ahí
está está raro dan y gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica nos vamos hasta parís